28 et puis football toujours les
sportifs ont du coeur puisqu'ils se sont
mobilisés pour aider coluche dans son
entreprise des restaurants du coeur une
bonne partie de la journée au palais des
sports de saint-ouen chanteur
journaliste footballeurs se sont relayés
pour des mini rencontre au profit des
restaurants du coeur et lionel
chamoulaud était au rendez vous gérard
jugnot et cyril neveu patrice martin
thierry rey jean claude dauphin
luis fernandez jean tigana et cetera et
cetera et cetera
acteurs chanteurs sportifs journalistes
tous étaient à saint-ouen ou short
autour de l'an x ray nationale pour en
soir gardien de but est ravi de voir le
football au service des restos du coeur
gauche lâchement content il faudrait que
tout le monde fasse à quoi tu vois alors
ce que ce qu'on veut faire c'est que on
va on va faire ça une fois par an de
manière à relancer un peu la faire quoi
tout est à chaque fois
et puis après ça les gens ils vont nous
aider et ont comme ça on va nourrir tout
le monde
près de 5000 personnes dans un gymnase
pour rigoler pour s'amuser pour donner
une action menée par l'autre agnoli
vielles reptiles système pour montrer
que les sportifs ont du coeur données
pour les restaurants du coeur sauf et
sportif et on a super plateau de
sportifs tout le monde a répondu présent
un type comme joël bats a même payé sa
place pour venir comme un spectateur
normal et ça je crois que c'est le
meilleur exemple que les sportifs
pouvaient donner
aux restos du coeur chacun a donné selon
ses moyens ses possibilités les plus
jeunes ne sont pas les plus radins
mobilisation générale du monde du
football 15 tonnes de fruits et légumes
offerts par le président de l'olympique
lyonnais
des pâtes par kilo et ont tout près de
300 mille francs seront récoltés grâce à
ce tournoi de foot
alors merci qui